welcome to this video playing demian
from germany a teammate of mine
he's not playing
maybe sending me a message sometimes
does that
but still you should play at some point
at least
20 seconds
down okay i'm going to
try something different what i normally
don't play
just want to have a different position
but bishop b4 is this this is
yeah i can i can also play this a cop of
variation
a3 very early a3
yeah i guess i have to oops i have to
make sure that i have a7 here
ah that's interesting and now he goes
for knight e2
for knight e2 setup this is in fact
questionable earlier because or let's
say not questionable is too strong but
black has ideas of playing d5 and this
is now not possible
there are gambit ideas i can show this
after the game
okay
i really don't know this position type
very well
yeah he puts his pudding and night there
that this really
really logical
hmm
if i take it i mean
i have a good development at least if i
if i take it knight here in c6
okay it looks slightly anti-positional
to take with the take with the bishop
but
i at least have a good as mentioned a
good development
hmm okay
didn't really
expected this move
can i do something to
to use my my bishop here
activating the queen or something
h5 h5 ideas or something
i don't know
i'm a bit unsure about this position
what to do
don't like it very much
yeah maybe the capture really was uh
was too fishy
okay
try to irritate him a little bit if it
is
if the whole
position here gets too
too static without any concrete ideas
then it will be problematic
the c7 pawn for example will be
yeah
this this opens up my bishop quite
considerably
i cannot play oops i cannot play knight
d4 really but he can play d4 now himself
maybe 94 will take and then the pawn is
just weak
i was thinking that c6 might be
something now c6 takes knight takes
hmm
yeah okay
i have to
i have to do that probably
it's not taking quickly which surprises
me
okay well that's not a bad idea
but okay i have to take this no much
okay
but this
i don't know is this really so great
now his bishop on g2 is not really
looking very threatening
and i either get this exchange or yes to
retweet it
okay
yeah this does not look so so bad i
think
queen might enter here
i probably should just
get get this traded
hmm
yeah
i don't know
should it be
is it really advisable
to trade rooks hmm what is the plan for
wine
okay i'm going to cover d6 first
i would like to make sure that my pawns
here
are not
fixed on light squares
ah that's interesting okay i will take
first
knight d7 e5 i have
i will first of all put this on dark
squares
yeah this is also meant to activate the
bishop yeah with bishop h3 at some point
but i think i have knight e5
which of course can be answered by f4
but this this is really a very weakening
move f4
which i really don't know if it is so
great
okay
he can give this check here
tia f4 does he really want to play a
form
not sure
it is really very weakening but
not something that i
that i can use immediately so it is
interesting
i after the check you might go to c6 by
the way
time warning
okay
that was an untimely phone call
yeah white has gained quite a lot of
space so
it probably was perfectly all right this
uh this business here
okay i have to stop f5 i think f5
immediately would have been more
forceful
unless i was overlooking something
so next i play a5 so that
i get this out of out of direct attack
so
yeah but how do i continue
i cannot invade with the queen
unfortunately which i would like i would
really like to do that but
i don't see how i can
manage this
queen c8 intending queen h3 or something
like that
queen c1 is possible now
yeah maybe that's a good idea
um yeah trading
trading queens is not a good idea i have
i've got very much less time
going to take this
i really don't uh don't think i can do
much here
i mean his king is a little bit insecure
but from a structural point of view why
this is good i mean
for example it would be a big mistake to
trade queens now the king is
has all the ideas
and i mean i can probably cover this but
but it's this is not a good idea but i
can of course continue here with
something like that
arguing that um
that his king is is really a problem
oh yeah the computer actually thinks
think that this is pretty good for black
yeah it's possible but i really didn't
have much time so i was was okay with
the draw definitely
and i had a disadvantage for most of the
game
okay thanks for watching